si comme moi vous avez aussi vu passer
l'information sur les réseaux sociaux
vous avez sans doute été intrigués je
vous parle des bulles qui Games il
s'agit du plus grand parcours gonflable
d'Europe et il sera de passage dans les
Yvelines ce samedi 9 septembre sur l'île
de loisirs de 50 ans en Yvelines pour en
parler avec nous Florian Fillon bonjour
bonjour alors vous êtes le responsable
des bulles qui Games première question
Florian il y a combien d'obstacles sur
ce plus grand parcours gonflable
d'Europe alors là nous sommes sur un
parcours qui fait 5 km et nous avons sur
ce parcours 12 structures gonflables
géantes et donc c'est quoi ces obstacles
ces structures gonflables c'est parfait
parce qu'on est sur une des structures
notamment qui s'appelle No gravity donc
là vous voyez c'est un obstacle que l'on
doit franchir on doit parcourir ces
différents boudins pour sortir de cet
obstacle donc les participants ont le
choix quand ils franchissent l'obstacle
ils peuvent soit rebondir sur les
trampolines qui sont entre chaque boudin
ou alors faire le choix de monter sur le
boudins et de sauter de boudin au boudin
qui est la solution
la possibilité pour tous alors c'est un
concept qui date depuis plusieurs années
est-ce que vous savez d'où est venu
l'idée de créer le plus grand parcours
gonflable d'Europe alors les deux
cofondateurs de la société sont partis
un petit peu à l'époque où les courses
d'obstacles étaient vraiment à la mode
son parti un peu dans différents pays et
notamment en Australie où ils ont repéré
ce genre d'événements qui avaient lieu
et qui rassemblée vraiment beaucoup de
monde avec un esprit très festif et ici
sont retrouvés dans ces valeurs là et
donc tout simplement ils ont voulu en
mettant leurs pattes apporter ce concept
ici en Belgique tout d'abord puis en
France donc c'est comme ça que
l'histoire a débuté et donc en France
vous tournez un petit peu il y a
plusieurs dates qui sont proposées
exactement cette année là sur 203 nous
avions 11 dates en France
la France est un marché très intéressant
mais il faut savoir aussi qu'on est
présent au Luxembourg en Belgique en
Espagne en Italie et en Suisse donc
l'expansion continue et donc ce samedi 9
septembre vous attendez combien de
personnes environ alors on attend 6000
personnes ce samedi sur la base de
loisirs de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
comme on dit dans le métier c'est à dire
qu'on a réussi à vendre tout nos billets
à l'avance donc on est vraiment très
très fiers d'autant plus que c'est la
deuxième date que l'on fait dans la
région parisienne cette année on en
avait fait une sur la base de loisirs de
vert Torcy et donc là de pouvoir être
ici en septembre et de nouveaux faire
sold out pour nous c'est génial donc là
si je comprends bien il reste plus de
place malheureusement par contre il
reste de la place pour tous les
accompagnateurs et les gens il faut
savoir qu'on est aussi un événement qui
est ouvert à tous ça c'est très
important parce que nous avons un
village avec de l'animation DJ bar food
truck animation gratuite comme ça les
gens peuvent vraiment venir en profiter
entre amis en famille avec une belle
journée comme ça on a des zones d'ombre
on a tout ce qu'il faut pour ravir tout
le monde il y a des animations avant et
après la course alors vous utilisez le
terme course mais il n'y a pas de
classement c'est c'est vraiment pour
s'amuser en fait c'est pour s'amuser on
aime bien utiliser le mot course parce
que ça reste certaines personnes quand
même un challenge de devoir gravir
certains obstacles de devoir affronter
aussi certains certaines choses que nous
rajoutons on a quand même le plus la
plus grande glissade de l'Europe qui
fait 13 mètres de haut il faut quand
même accéder en haut on y arrive par le
biais d'une corde donc il y a quand même
un petit effort physique sur certains
obstacles c'est très léger mais pour
certaines personnes ça représente quand
même un challenge donc on aime bien
garder ce génie ce terme générique on va
dire course si on a un peu le vertige on
c'est faisable non non franchement il y
a pas il y a pas de quoi avoir peur
là-haut nous avons les bénévoles et le
staff qui est présent pour rassurer pour
indiquer toutes les mesures de sécurité
donc non aucun problème alors en moyenne
on termine en combien de temps ce
parcours les gens en moyenne mettent
entre 1h15 j'ai envie de dire parce que
il faut savoir que 95% des gens vont le
faire en marchant ils vont partir à fond
ils vont faire la première structure et
après ils vont se sentir assez essoufflé
et ils vont se dire allez on va quand
même profiter et donc du coup les gens
mettent plutôt une heure donc vous
l'avez testé je suppose ce parcours d'un
témoin je le connais par coeur merci
beaucoup Florian Fillon d'avoir répondu
à nos questions c'est la fin de ce 7 8
invité je vous souhaite une belle soirée
sur TV 78 merci pour votre fidélité
prenez soin de vous